grauer star kann in zukunft geheilt
werden aufgezeichnete sonneneruption und
wird wtf 90 f auf der erde einschlagen
das sind nur drei der fünf themen in den
krieg zum top news vor zwei wochen
hatten wir euch irgendwie zum topf -
eine nasa animation von einem schwarzen
loch gezeigt unter anderem wurde gefragt
was das besondere an dieser animation
sei animationen bei uns sind immer top
aktuell also gerade veröffentlicht von
der nasa und heute haben wir für euch
wieder was besonderes und zwar besser
gesagt zwei besondere aufnahmen eine
davon kommt jetzt wie stellt ihr euch
nennt eine sonneneruption also sozusagen
ein erdbeben das ist es ja auch auf der
sonne vor ihr habt keine vorstellung
gleich seht ihr eine solche option
das dkfz das deutsche
krebsforschungszentrum hat nach sechs
jahren den zweiten tag atlas publiziert
das traurige ergebnis zum einen sterben
rund 121.000 deutsche jährlich durch
rauchen bzw einem folgen und 33 prozent
der männer und rund 20 prozent der
frauen sind raucherinnen beziehungsweise
12 prozent der elf bis 17 jahre alten
kinder und jugendlichen rauchen dabei
dürfen tabak haltige genussmittel erst
ab 18 jahren gekauft werden
da sind dann zwölf prozent doch viel
viel jugendlichen sehen ja wasserpfeifen
als ungefährlich an ist das aber auch so
eine der autoren des tabak atlas 2015
martina reschke lager sagte folgendes
zitat wasserpfeifen sind genauso
gefährlich wie tabak zigaretten
denn sie enthalten jahr verbrannten
tabak die ganzen krebserzeugende stoffe
die durch die verbrennung entstehen
werden auch beim wasserpfeifen raucher
inhaliert weltraumschrott fällt auf
unsere erde wenn man sich diese
illustration der esa ansieht muss man
sich langsam nicht mehr wundern wenn
weltraumschrott auf die erde fällt und
zwar ziemlich regelmäßig oder eine
weltraumstation iss trifft erst das
könnte am 13 november passieren wtf 90 f
ist ein alter bekannter 2013 wurde
dieses objekt zum ersten mal gesichtet
schon damals war klar dass es irgendwann
in richtung erde stürzen wird klar ist
allerdings noch nicht was ewt f90 f ist
ein asteroid ist es auf jeden fall nicht
den fall ziemlich sicher es ist unter
anderem die rede von einem kleineren
raketen teil eine direkte gefahr geht
nicht von dem objekt auf aus zitat wir
gehen davon aus dass ein großer teil
wenn nicht alles in der atmosphäre
verbrennen wird so tim flora der am
europäischen raumflugkontrollzentrum
esoc arbeitet falls doch etwas übrig
bleibt landet das voraussichtlich im
indischen ozean
es besteht also erstmal kein grund zur
sorge
kommen wir zum zweiten spektakulären
video im fachmagazin science wurde von
forschern der university of colorado in
boulder über einen gewaltigen
sonnensturm berichtet die sonne maven
hat vor fünf monaten unter anderem
kohlendioxid und sauerstoff ionen im
umfeld des mars entdeckt diese haben
aufgrund von sonnenstürmen ja den weg
ins all gefunden sonnenstürme könnten
also für die geringe dichte der mars
atmosphäre verantwortlich seien früher
seien solche stürme nämlich weitaus
öfter vorgekommen wie das ganze szenario
aussieht das könnt ihr jetzt in einer
wirklich in einem klasse video
betrachten
auf der erde schützt uns übrigens unser
magnetfeld vor den auswirkungen der
sonnenstürme an sonst wärst hier ähnlich
trostlos wie auf dem mars rover stark an
in zukunft geheilt werden sehr viele
menschen darunter auch absolute genies
wie beispielsweise johann sebastian bach
sind aufgrund des grauen star erblindet
bisher galt die krankheit als unheilbar
und die menschliche linse wurde im
rahmen einer operation entfernt und
durch eine künstliche ersetzt was aber
zahlreiche nachteile hat forscher der
university of michigan in ann arbour
haben jetzt im fachmagazin science eine
neue behandlungsmethode vorgestellt das
besondere an ihr es muss nicht mehr
operiert werden unsere linse besteht ja
unter anderem aus flüssigen proteinen
leidet man unter grauem star stocken
diese langsam sowie eiweiß in kochendem
wasser folge mal verliert nach und nach
sein augenlicht die linse trübt ein
die forscher konnten jetzt mit einem
präparat dieses stocken verhindern und
sogar wieder rückgängig machen
bei versuchen mit mäusen gelang
erstaunliches schon nach 14 tagen zeigte
sich die gewünschte wirkung bei leichen
entnommene menschlichen augenlinsen
konnte man ebenso ein positives resultat
verzeichnen
die studienautoren selbst sind jetzt
ziemlich begeistert von ihrer arbeit
zitat damit kann präparat 29 eine
vielversprechende spur zu einer nicht
operativen therapie seien sowohl von
erblichen als auch von altersbedingten
katarakten zitat ende
setzt sich diese medikamentöse
behandlung irgendwann durch
beziehungsweise wird sie routine könnte
das tausenden menschen das augenlicht
zurückgeben und die operationen werden
überflüssig ihre vorstellung oder was
sagt ihr dazu könnte diese entdeckung
ein riesiger forschungserfolg
diskutiertes in den kommentaren und noch
ein hinweis nichts mehr hier verpassen
klicks um abonnieren trotzdem ja nichts
also freue ich mich über jedes auto das
wir da last und schaut euch das nächste
video ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran